president-elect joe biden has now  announced more nominations to help lead  his health policies  the nominees include california attorney  general javier becerra  to be the health and human services  secretary dr vivette  vivek murthy to once again be the u.s  surgeon general  and dr richelle walensky to head the  centers for disease control  the president-elect's coronavia risk  advisory board says the trump  administration has  yet to share plans for distributing the  vaccines for covet 19.  we want to be preventing deaths and we  want to be preventing transmission  and you can't really make a plan for  that if you don't know what tools you're  working with